thank you
okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
uh to all the members of uh the overview
and scrutiny panel I welcome you to our
meeting of the 14th of March 2023
um the meeting is now going to begin I'd
also like to welcome the gentleman John
and Tim I hope you don't mind me using
your Christian names John and Tim who
are here representing Southern water one
of the items on the agenda a little bit
later we'll be hearing from them to the
officers of the council who are
supporting us as always in the
preparation of this meeting and I know
in particular there's been quite a lot
of background work that's had to go on
to produce this meeting so thank you for
that and also of course two members of
the public as well as other councilors
from the district who are joining us may
I welcome you to this meeting
and we hope that for you it is a
positive experience in seeing your
council at work and in seeing a response
from a body from outside of this Council
who have been invited to come and talk
to us and I I use the word invited quite
strongly because it is an invitation so
I would respectfully ask everybody to
remember that although the council has
the right to ask outside organizations
to come in particularly in areas that
affect
shouldn't use the word areas twice it
matters that affect the area
it is always an invitation so personally
thank you very much for coming once more
to be able to speak with us this evening
moving on then to the fire alarm
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices down
the main staircase opposite the lifts in
the foyer and we'll assemble in Hawley
Square on the green officers will assist
us if it's when it's deemed advisable to
return
with everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
or flight mode or something like that so
they are not used to receive or make
phone calls text messages and so on
other ways of disturbing the meeting
this meeting is being live streamed for
members of the public to observe as well
and it will be recorded and subsequently
brought broadcast on the internet does
anyone here intend to film the meeting
no I'm not seeing any
signs of that during the course of the
evening speaking under Council rule 20.1
are the following members of the council
item number four the southern water
presentation councilor Ghana councilor
Bailey
and councilor Roth is that is that
correct councilman
uh uh are there any other counselors
with us who may wish to speak no okay
um public speaking I've received the
following requests for public speaking
on a gender item four first then the
southern water presentation Ms Elizabeth
Wickenden and Ms Jackie Brown and Jackie
Brown it says here is representing
Westgate and Garland's Action Group
against Housing Development on farmland
on agenda item five the collaboration
working party report we have councilor
Hudson chair of birchington Parish
Council this is councilman yeah welcome
to you
we will come to you for that item as
well
so the agenda items uh substantive items
on the agenda then apologies for absence
I have received apologies for the
following members councilor Elise is
substituted by councilor roseki
councilor Wing is substituted by
councilor Smith
councilor patmore is substituted by
councilor Yates and councilor ratigan is
substituted by councilor towning thank
you very much for coming and joining the
meeting this evening
are there any Declarations of interest
that members need to make
gender item number three then to approve
the minutes of the overview and scrutiny
panel meeting held on the 16th of
February 2023 there is a copy attached
to the agenda pack can I have a proposal
please for those minutes
thank you very much
and can I have a second to please thank
you Council Austin
do members agree thank you very much
[Applause]
and so we move to item number four on
our agenda the southern water
presentation and under our public
speaking facilities I would now like to
invite Miss Wickenden to come to a
microphone and address the meeting this
weekend
[Music]
um good evening my name is Elizabeth
Wickenden I am a resident of the Wimpy
estate in broadstairs which is situated
very close to the ronfield road power
station which obviously has had a lot of
incidents recently uh my question to
Southern water is for the December 2022
water outages across than it why have
you as a Company Southern water been so
sporadic in how compensation or Goodwill
payments have been credited to customers
accounts and why are there differences
in payment amounts and finally why are
there still a high number of wimpy
estate customers who are still waiting
for their compensation money to be
credited to their accounts
thank you
thank you very much Mr given
um we will be listening very carefully
when the presentation comes and we hope
that that question will be addressed
during the presentation thank you very
much indeed
and now then uh Miss Jackie Brown
pleased to ask a question
good evening I'm Jackie Brown and I'm
representing the Westgate pingard
injection group against Housing
Development on farmland and I'd like to
ask Southern water if developments of 21
000 houses across than it receive
planning permission I'll have more to
able to give residents assurances they
will be able to deliver a reliable water
supply and the sewage Villages into the
sea will not increase
given that all area the area already
experiences this and there will be no
negative impacts on communities across
the district for more to supply and
sewage treatment and Disposal issues
thank you
thank you very much for being willing to
come and talk to the panel again we'll
make sure we'll listen very carefully to
ensure that that is addressed during the
course of the presentation
speaking under rule 20.1 in the council
then first of all can I ask councilor
Governor could you address
the panel thank you
thank you hello
um I'm pleased to have this opportunity
to speak as one of the Saint Peter's
Ward councilors which covers the Wimpy
estate in broadstairs and I'm going to
be speaking on both the subject areas
highlighted within the committee report
that's the outages in December and
January and your long-term
infrastructure plan
so regarding the outages in December and
January well you've heard you've heard
from one resident from the Wimpy estate
you asked about compensation payments
I've been contacted by a number of other
residents on the Wimpy estate and the
surrounding area of broadstairs since
last December about these and other
outages
these residents and I will declare an
interest here I'm one of them bear the
brunt of any outages at The runfield
Road Site both through the resulting
lack of water and then through traffic
impacts caused by road closures in the
vicinity a large number who contact me
haven't received any compensation
since the outages last December despite
a few being in regular contact either by
phone or email one of them whose name
and contact details I can provide
separately ask me to read the cell
the service Southern water has provided
since December last year has been
appalling the four water outages have
affected myself and my family greatly
especially the ones that occurred on the
19th and 20th of December
on the 19th of December I had to attend
hospital for two procedures prior to
surgery for breast cancer on the 20th of
December not only could I not have a
decent basic wash before the procedures
on the 19th I couldn't have a bath or
shower before my surgery on the 20th due
to these circumstances I was unable to
drive during this time so get into a
water station after a very long day at
the hospital was absolutely horrendous
the cues for water were extremely
lengthy I had to get a lift from a
friend and bring my son as I was unable
to lift anything
thus far I have received no compensation
whatsoever for this other water and I've
had to chase it the whole situation is
totally unacceptable and I did check
with this lady yesterday and she hasn't
received any compensation as yet
the majority of residents in broadstairs
have been impacted by these outages
especially the one on the 19th and 20th
of December which acknowledged on your
website as it was happening lasted over
24 hours
so why haven't you automatically made a
payment of 60 pound to all of these
residents
this would then have enabled your
customer service staff to deal with
residents with additional needs and
requirements
so next your long-term infrastructure
development plan
we all know as it stands Southern Waters
water supply and treatment
infrastructure is not fit for purpose if
it were we would not have had frequent
water outages over the last few months
and you would not be regularly pumping
sewage off our Coastline as has been
happening and not improving for a number
of years now
as reported by SOS whitstable just this
week
in the 167 hours that elapsed between
episode 1 and episode 2 of Paul
whitehouse's troubled Rivers series
You released 931 hours worth of sewage
into the waterways across the southeast
this is completely unacceptable
our public meeting in Ramsgate a year
ago your previous CEO Ian McCauley
talked to us about upgrades planned to
the infrastructure to improve matters
as far as most of us are concerned
nothing has improved
I believe in fact that things are
worsening as a council there is little
we can do to regulate how you manage
your water supply and treatment
infrastructure that's the job of off
what the environment agency and our
government all of whom continue to fail
abjectly in their responsibilities
what I believe we could do as a council
though
is to stop making the situation worse by
continuing to give permission for new
large Housing Development
[Music]
until until you can convince us that
your infrastructure is fit for purpose
and by that I mean by providing a
reliable water supply and no more sewage
in the sea
so I look forward to seeing your
your long-term infrastructure
development plan presentation
to the panel and hearing how and when
the work required will be done thank you
remember
[Applause]
Ghana there is no I'll just say there is
no official time limit for comments
speaking under rule 20.1 I've tried to
be as generous as I can but could I ask
you just to bear in mind how long the
question is how long you're going to
take to make your points thank you for
that very thorough I know it's affected
your award particularly and also that's
the case with councilor Bailey please
thank you good evening
I just really have a list of bullet
point of questions I'm speaking on
behalf of my residents in my award which
is Viking Ward which is also severely
impacted by the recent Spate of water
outages
there's been a great deal of anger and
frustration regarding both the repeated
loss of water supply and the
inconsistencies and delays around
compensation
so my bullet points really is one is
communication
I think it's very patchy in two respects
during each of these recent outages
there's been very little information on
the website or social media pages of
Southern water and we've had to chase
information and and actually report
these outages ourselves in a lot of
cases
um
the most important most important thing
people want to know is how long they're
likely to be without water
and can there not be a quicker mechanism
for alerting customers to problems
the second point about communication is
that customers have tried using multiple
platforms for contacting Southern water
with incred incredibly varying outcomes
South Water Southern water seems to be
putting the onus on individual customers
to prove how long they were without
water but surely Southern water must
have a mechanism for knowing who has
lost water and for how long
um my next Point's about the bottled
water
during the prolonged outage in December
the delivery of water bottles to
Priority customers was very patchy with
many not receiving them at all
and the second point there was initially
one water station set up Dame Park
school and then another Asda which was
quickly changed to St George's but all
three locations were in an extremely
small busy area within stands for of
each other
um and in future if it ever happened
again it would be better to separate
these sites to reduce the impact on
local traffic
um the next point where it has been
covered about compensation that seems to
be an absolutely no consistency with
payments Southern water must must have
known during the prolonged outage in
December that it lasted more than 24
hours and for many more than 36 hours
yet the initial payments if people
received them did not reflect this
summer accounts were automatically
credited yet some people unbelievably
still now three months later still
haven't received any compensation
while some people haven't received any
others have received payments varying
between
30 pounds and 200 pounds and it's even
reported that some people receive
compensation even though they didn't
lose water
I also
don't know
um I've not heard anything about
business compensation
um it's inconvenient enough to
households to lose water but it's even
worse for businesses so they're trying
to especially in this climate have they
been adequately compensated
um I did suggest in a tweet to Southern
water that in addition to the
um the services standards of um 30
pounds hour per hour compensation you
maybe also need to make compensation
payments for multiple outages within a
certain time frame because residents
really need to rely on consistent
service
and finally
how can residents have any faith in a
regular water supply going forward
especially with the thousands of new
homes planned in thanet thank you
thank you councilor Bailey councilor
Ross please
thank you chair good evening everyone
and thank you to those councilors that
invited Southern water to this meeting
to give this opportunity to everyone to
express their feeling and also ask their
questions
and I have asked some local farmers and
many residents in thanet has told me
Farmers used to take a seaweed use them
and this is on their cost for free
and this year alone family District
Council had to put twenty thousand pound
on the side to clear the seaweed on a
coasted inside
and the farmers cannot use these because
it's been contaminated by human waste
air should not pay
for the mess if sauce and water cannot
cope with the human waste and Theory
can you please tell us
what measure in place to taxpayers money
not to be waste of cleaning after this
sea which that's been put in the sea and
also will you be happy to cover the cost
if this has happened in the future thank
you
thank you very much councilworth
um thank you for all the questions from
the public and from the councilors I'm
sure our guests have been listening very
carefully and we'll try and cover as
many of the points as they can
um
I'd now like to welcome Mr Tim McMahon
formerly and Mr John mealy formerly who
are going to come and make their
presentation dealing with some of the
issues that have been raised and perhaps
other issues that we may not be aware of
in terms of infrastructure issues but to
give us as full a briefing as they
possibly can at this time thank you very
much
and thank you very much for hearing us
today if I can introduce myself again
I'm Tim McMann and I'm the water
operations director for southern water
so my responsibility is extracting water
from our rivers or underground all the
way through to customers for our water
assets our drinking drinking water
um but obviously I'm here as a
spokesperson for southern water today so
I will try and answer some of the other
broader questions around Wastewater as
as we as we as we go
um so in terms of the presentation today
um I want to use this time to talk
through the supply impact the customers
at broadstairs Ramsgate Manson and
Margate experienced over the last few
months this was initially due to a burst
water main and I'll go into a bit more
detail what that means in in a second
followed by a number of power failures
on our on our site which I'll again I'll
explain in a bit more a bit more detail
so the purpose of the slides is to give
you an overview of what happened and how
how we're resolving it or how we've
resolve moved it and I will look to
answer some of the questions that have
been just related to my to myself but I
would like to apologize in the first
instance for the the impact that our
customers have seen the multiple Supply
interruptions seen by customers is not
acceptable
um it's been lots of challenges around
it all for the right intentions which
I'll take you through in a minute in
terms of making that area more resilient
and through the investment we've been
putting in train but we should have been
better at stopping it from happening in
the first place so I would like to
apologize for the impact customers have
seen in these instance
so um just in terms of context how this
network works
um so it's quite a complicated area in
how we've been having to operate it in
the last few months but it in summary
the purple circle illustrates the
customers that have been impacted
through the recent events and that
accounts to 13 just over 13 300
properties that's the light blue section
indicated by the purple section
there is a there is a customer base to
the north
um which is about 7 000 properties but
we're lucky in that area that that has
two feeds one from the tower which you
saw in the previous page but also one
from a booster station called Mars gate
booster station which means we can
Market booster station sorry so it means
we can which means we can supply the
customers from two sources so if you
lose the Tower or lose the supply that
feeds a tower
um we have an option to to cover that
there's that customer base with a
different water supply so the customer's
impacted those in the purple circle
and that that customer base is usually
supplied by the tower and that Tower is
really important because that's a
reservoir with drinkable water in which
can hold water for up to six hours so if
you have a problem with the pumps that
feed that Tower we have six hours to
respond
okay we um over the last six months have
spent a million pounds on that Tower to
upgrade it I.E and extend its asset life
because there were problems with the
Civil infrastructure and it had leaks
within it so we had to fix that to
extend its life and use that as a really
important source for resilient supply
for customers so that meant on point
four
um the tower out of supply
that that 13 300 customers were
supported by two pumps so a pumping
station which isn't our practice that
that happens a lot across the water
industry but it was a different Supply
approach to what we normally would
normally have in place and that means
the second those pumps were to fail or
the pipe would fail
um Associated to that that those that
those pumps you'd see it automatic
customer impact immediate customer
impact as opposed to the normal six hour
response that we can we can have so
that's important context as to why
um we would have seen some of those
those impacts which shouldn't have
happened but if the tower was in Supply
only one of the instances that we've
seen would have actually of course a
customer Interruption so it's an
important context that Tower is a very
important asset for the resilience of
that that customer area
so in just a bit of detail then some of
the incidents that we we've seen so um
on the 19th of December we had a burst
water pipe when temperatures
um were very cold if you remember
mid-December then got very warm suddenly
and we saw that pipe pipe burst at the
actual Tower itself just beyond the
pumps beyond the boosters
um we're still trying to understand and
investigate the root cause for that
through various investigations we're
doing but it looks like that was due to
something called stress loading which is
where and there's lots and lots of
reasons why a pipe will burst but it
basically means there was something
sitting on that pipe when it was
installed 70 80 years ago which has
caused caused straight on that pipe
before it to fail but that meant 9 000
properties were out of water for more
than 33 three hours and I'll get I'll
give you a bit more of a breakdown on
that in a second
then on the 12th and 15th of January we
saw local outages
um in in that area which was causing our
boosters to pump so different Power
fluctuations in the network which has
caused these bump pumps to trip which
saw two interruptions for about an hour
um each each time
on the 21st of January we had a Mains
power failure at 7 pm which means so a
pumping station is fed through two
sources you have Mains power from the
from the grid
um but if that were to fail you have a
generator which can kick in to supply
the pumps with power those that
generator wasn't tested a week before
um but the starter motor which kicks in
when the when the in the when the power
failed didn't come in and that that
generator failed so that meant four
thousand just over four thousand
properties were left without water for
11 hours so that generator should have
worked and it didn't
um in that in that instance
off the back of that we did
um quite a lot of activity to improve
um the sort of the inlets to the pumps
the power so the support for those pumps
and started to man the site 24 7 to
ensure that we had the right response
um as part of the 30th of January trends
of looking at getting that Tower back in
and get water into it to test if it had
leaks in it or not there was a short
outage of 30 minutes
um which was part of the the maintenance
work we were doing to get water into the
asset base and on the 23rd of February
the pumps failed again because of a a
fluctuation in power but because it was
a 24 7-man site we were able to get that
Supply back up and running within 30
minutes as opposed to having to wait
sorry 45 minutes I suppose having to
wait until
individuals to attend sites
okay so that gives you a bit of a
rundown of what has happened in the
frequency of of events
um so what have we done in the short
term
um so we've completed various
electricity electrical maintenance Works
in January to understand and improve the
use of the generator so we've changed
our generator changed the motors of
another generator to ensure that that
was available in case there was a power
power failure
um we've manned the site 24 7 and that's
continued to to be so
um and then during the power outages
we've had the ability to switch over to
that chat generator if needed and as of
yesterday the tower is now back in
Supply after that one million pound
investment which is great news because
that means we have a six hour
contingency before we'd see customer
Interruption compared to how it's been
operating over the last the last six
months
longer term
um we that that pumping station element
of the of the of the of the tower still
needs to be made more resilient so
there's various
um works we need to do on that site
around the control system and the
starter Motors and the power connectors
to that to that site and that's going to
cost about 250 000 pounds we're
investing that and that will take about
six months predominantly um the time is
predominantly due to lead time for some
of these kit connectors
um with the sort of worldwide shortage
of microchips at the moment and that
sort of um equipment that's needed is
proven quite it's got quite a lot called
on lead time but we're very much
committed to to that investment and
making that pumping station more
resilient
um as I say with the tower in that's a
good it's a good thing it improves
resilience but we want to make sure that
there isn't any issues with this
particular asset going going forward and
then over the next
um Year we're forming our what we call
our final determination with our
economic regulator off what to form our
plan from 2025 to 2030 which is setting
our plans in place for this area and The
Wider Southern water area and that
includes things such as what are we
doing around long-term climate change so
um water recycling potentially
desalination plants if required all the
way through to reducing leakage by a
further 15 by 2030 and a significant
Mains replacement program in that in
that space
he's still very early stage I can I can
give you some detail of particular
locations where we are looking to do
work but I think it's important to note
that has to go through a lot of
regulatory scrutiny before that can be
confirmed
um in writing as to what we'll be doing
for this area and The Wider Southern
Southern water area
in terms of how we compensate customers
so
in the water industry we follow
something called the guaranteed standard
scheme this is a regulatory condition
set by by off what which means for every
12 hours that customers are impacted we
have to pay them 30 pounds for
households and for non-households that's
fish chops all the way through to
factories and it's 75 pounds
um and we have to proactively identify
those those customers and recompense
them through
um reducing their reducing their bills
or putting money into their account
um we do that it's quite a complicated
process but if if you imagine
um on the if you remember the first page
that light blue section there was
squares those squares are something
called dma so District metered areas and
um of our area we have about 1600 of
these dmas and each of these distributed
areas have a flow probe and pressure
probe that feeds the error called a
district meter and at the High Point a
pressure logger and what we do from that
is understand those data points and look
at the how the bands of households in
the dma and run some Hydraulics to
understand who would be in and out of
Supply because as you can imagine
um some will be cut off quick earlier
than others because of the the
topography that we're looking at and
some will return quicker than others
depending on the network and the
topography that we look at so we go
through a process where
um that that's checked
um by an operative who's been doing it
for a long time
um through the sort of the data set that
we we've used for about five years and
we then manually check that again
through uh we assure that with a
separate individual and then that's
checked by by management for we then
submit that to our customer service team
who relays that to to to our customers
by by compensating them
and in terms of the um what what who was
impacted and the sort of the total
compensation paid in December
um he impacted a total of 13 395
customers in total
um so 12 000 household I was over 12 000
household just over a thousand
non-household
um for a duration of up to 24 hours
and the GSS payments were made
for
9696 households and
1043 non-households within a 20-day
deadline that was paid by the 20th of
January
um unfortunately 2656 household
customers were paid late and an
additional payment was made of 20 20
pounds that was a processing error on
our part which we shouldn't have made so
I have to hold our hands up for that
that is a failing apart but we we found
it through obviously some of the
complaints we're getting and obviously
recompense customers and paid an extra
20 pound
household customers have obviously
received letters to denote them of that
information of that payment
and obviously with the non-household
customers we have to inform the retailer
of the payments so they can they can
credit the customer's account
I mean in terms of what else have been
doing around customers we note that
um there's obviously a lot of customer
concern around
um the water supply in in the area and
as of this afternoon we actually came
away from a session where we've been
meeting customers to talk to them to to
Listen to Apologize
um and also give them some assurances of
the work we've been doing and understand
any wider concerns they've got around
around Southern Southern water
so that's sort of the slides if I can
just if I may check and address some of
the the questions that
um we we heard so in terms of
um the particular State the state in
question I would have to take that away
and confirm as to
um and look at the data to understand
why they may or may not have been been
missed and feed that back to the team I
think it's important we note that the
process if we have
um missed customers with our with our
data set
um the process we we're following at the
moment is if a customer contacts us and
believes they haven't been recompensed
with the right amount or we've got the
data wrong we are looking at the
case-by-case basis and recompensing the
customer accordingly but I will take the
Wimpy estate customers a way to speak to
the team as to why that's not that's not
happened and clearly if we have missed
them we will look to recompense those
those customers
um I think if I may have come to the
development side at the end if I can
just finish around the rumsfield
rumsfield area then in terms of
the outages
um and
um
the oh again long-term plan
um there's question around
Communications and our website and Pages
this is an area we are
continuously trying to improve within
within Southern water
um we do a lot now on text messaging we
did a lot on radio
um to try and keep customers informed on
our website we've since then improved
our website further so that's something
that we do look to improve we are seeing
um you know information coming back from
our some customs from surveys we have
after these bigger events that is
getting better but it's a journey that
we're on and something we are
continuously looking to to improve and
we are looking to get our website better
in terms of getting more information
available which is it definitely needs
to to improve in that in that space
um in terms of bottled water the two
stations
um we're currently looking with our
local resilience forums to look at where
we can better install bottled water at
high risk locations this being obviously
one of them due to the the volume of
impacts and the volume events we've had
historically
but the real challenge we have in this
space is getting suitable locations they
need to be big
so you get the right Ingress and egress
for vehicles they need to have good
traffic management facilities and
they've got to be we've got to be able
to get onto them ideally they're not
being used for something else and this
area is quite challenging for that so
working with the local residence forums
to identify other ones we will continue
to do but we are inhibited by scale and
size for bottled water water stations
um again it's something we are trying to
improve on an event an event by basis
um that has got better
um for context in terms of the last big
event pre this event in terms of the
Isle of shepi we were able to distribute
four times more bottled water than what
we did in that event and then in terms
of our vulnerable customers we we
believe
um we responded and got bottled water
distributed bottled water to all of our
customers within 12 hours we are aware
that from the local resilience forums
there was about 130 that were flagged in
that day that we were then we added to
our list throughout that day and then
got water to them but it's this is a
challenge around we have a list that
list needs to get updated live as the
events go on because obviously not only
everyone will inform us of them being a
vulnerable customer so we try and
refresh that list as the event as the
event goes on
um there's a question around
non-household compensation I think which
hopefully I covered
um and then onto the development
questions
um so the first one is around the volume
of houses
um being looked at within within this
area
um so in terms of the water companies we
have a statutory duty to ensure
developments proceed we do not have the
ability to reject development
okay so we cannot force people to not to
develop what we should do though and
what we need to do and what we do try to
do is to work with the local planning
authorities to identify where our
constraints are so that can be put into
their conditions as part of the
development but we cannot say as if the
developer comes up and says we're going
to do ABC we cannot go well no we can't
do that because of ABC we have the duty
the statutory duty to support that but
we have to and we have to we have to try
to try to achieve that in that in that
in that process
clearly the um
Achilles in terms of
areas we need to improve as an industry
is we welcome things such as the new
such policy that's coming out from
government where they're actively
encouraging and driving developers to
install Suds
um so we're very supportive of that we
want to ensure developers are driving
more to neutrality so reducing usage for
use usage across the estate and their
development and looking at other areas
such as on white goods installing water
neutrality elements to it or reducing
water use within those white white goods
but as I say we cannot stop development
we can help influence it by getting
early in the process for local or
planning Authority so you can then
impose conditions on on developers but
we cannot reject them
yeah
correct and then um
the
question around
um seaweed and cost to Farmers and the
impact that has around human waste and
taxpayers absolutely we can if there
isn't if there is a
um
a discharge where there is if there's a
pollution and we are impacting that
product that is used for Farmers we will
we will look to compensate them for for
that and we'll definitely commit to that
um
I think they were the sort of hopefully
hopefully for the presentation I've
answered answered and they're quite the
customer sorry I forgot um councilor
Garner the customer in question you I
would definitely take that detail detail
away that sounds like a terrible case
thank you thank you very much
um hopefully that has answered the key
questions I'm sure I've missed some so
if I have I do apologize
um
sorry a big pardon so um so
so in terms of yeah that was it so in
terms of investment
um I think in terms of our previous CEO
what's been committed that there
have been improvements
um in terms of investment so if you look
at
um Margate and broadstairs we've
invested five million pounds on those
assets over the last last year and now
they are covered by operators 24 24 7.
so
um so in terms of The Operators that's
there for 24 7 so we can look to improve
operation operational and maintenance
activities of those of those assets and
if you look at discharges from our
consented sewer outfalls and to be clear
legal or illegal our stances is
unacceptable either way okay but if you
look at that year on year over the last
two years that's improved 30 year on
year and we're looking to improve that
by a further 50 by 2030 but that will
come at a cost at a tune of about a
billion pounds for southern water so
that is a significant level of
investment that's needed
um but that's not going to take time and
there's
there are um various activities we need
to to do in regard to that so looking at
how you stop rain water getting into
sewers number one number two looking at
how we better utilize our Network to
control flow of rainwater or sewage into
our sewer treatment works and then
thirdly look to expand our
infrastructure I make it bigger to
retain that rain water or sewage to stop
any spills that will take obviously a
lot of time and investment to to enable
new development
how are you dealing with it could be uh
uh could we please not call out from the
floor please we are we are trying to
listen and obviously the members of the
public who are listening to the film uh
the filming of this meeting cannot hear
any of your voices uh coming from the
back so it kind of won't make much sense
to them if if the gentlemen who are
speaking have to change their subject in
mid-sentence because I could just ask
you to bear with us I believe we are
getting as fulsome reply as to most of
the issues that we can but there will
always be issues that we feel there
hasn't been quite enough information
given but hopefully moving forward the
channels of communication being open we
can keep them open and learn more so
that your counselors can be of better
help and assistance to all residents
so I think um I think if I I think the
question was around sewage and future
future developments around around sewage
um so again in terms of when we have
development
um we look to increase or expand the
network or improve on the the network as
as required
um in terms of this area there is quite
a bit of work we're doing around
understanding and modeling the impact of
development which will which would lead
to We Believe in the next two to three
years investment in the sewer Network to
um capture that that sewage
aside The Wider investment we're doing
for between 2025 and 2030 around growth
um to to expand existing assets or
improve existing assets to capture
capture that that development usage
clearly as I say we need to work with
developers to reduce the amount of
um rain water or water entering our
servers and that is absolutely
fundamental that we we do that and get
support from government to work with
developers to to reduce that entering
entering the sewer as well
um I think I heard a question around net
profits I think it's important that we
recognize that
um the water industry the way we portray
P L's is pretty complicated
um the net profit isn't going to
shareholders it's going to cover debt in
terms of dividends which is basically
the the equity injection that goes to
shareholders there hasn't been an equity
payout since 2017 and in fact against
the money that we've been afforded by a
regulator
um I can't explain I can't detail the
exact amount it will be because it's
going through commercial conversations
with our shareholders at present but
will be the biggest likely to be the
biggest Equity injection in Industry
ever so
um our shareholders are very much trying
to invest and improve our investment Way
Beyond what's being afforded by our
economic regulator but when we when
people say net profit or read net profit
in the papers that is not cash going out
the door to fund or pay shareholders
that's dividends and we haven't paid
dividends since 2017 it's that net
profit is to several it's to cover debt
hmm
thank you very much does that conclude
the presentation I think I covered the
questions if I haven't I do apologize
um we'll come back to you during the
course of could I just ask you to knock
the mic off thank you very much
um I think I think a
um a major concern
is the rate or the pace at which
developments are happening and water I
think I've got the gist of what you're
saying the water supply and removal and
so on seems to be lagging behind quite
quite some distance and I think that's
what lay behind the question as to
whether or not we can call a halt to
these things I think you've answered
from a legal point of view that you
can't
prevent developers from building but
let's say if if I may just ask let's say
the the development has been given
planning uh permission and so on you've
negotiated with the planning Authority
the work has begun and they are the
bricks and mortar and the the carports
and the drives for the houses are way
ahead of water
service provision is your point of
contact at that point the developer or
is it with the planning Authority please
foreign
yes you have um obviously two stages at
the early onset of development we work
the local planning authority to give our
views as to what's
possible and what's not
um when a developer has built the bricks
and mortars and ready to connect we work
with the developer directly to either
enable the connection or enable or do
the connection ourselves to that
particular property
properties
thank you very much I'm now going to uh
open this up to our panel and if I can
turn first to councilor Keane then
councilor Curry and then councilor
Huxley please
thank you chair and thank you for coming
along tonight obviously this has been
very distressing for our residents and I
do appreciate that you were trying to
keep people informed via social media
and your website and that but these
incidents happened over a number of days
and each time it was a different reason
which you have explained tonight about
those different reasons but one thing
that particularly concerned me about
this is that again there was a failure
of the backup systems and the same thing
happened when we had the sewage releases
that backup systems failed I would have
expected I know it's different systems
I'm not conflating the two but I would
have expected following those sewage
failures that you as Southern water
would have undertaken a thorough review
of all your backup systems all of them
across the whole water supply to make
sure that those incidents couldn't
happen again and that doesn't seem to
have happened and I wonder why that
wasn't done because it's such an
important thing to be safeguarding our
water supply I can't understand how you
would have a failure and just kind of do
a bit of piecemeal repair
um
and so if it hasn't been done on both
systems the sewage and the drinking
water already can you assure us that
there will be an absolutely full review
of backup systems to make sure this
doesn't happen again and it does seem to
me that what you're talking about I
appreciate all the investment going in
now but didn't you realize that these
long-term improvements were needed a
long time ago and you know be working
towards that it just seems now we've had
some failures that these plans are
coming forward is this not indicative of
systemic long-term under investment
foreign
[Applause]
before we took the tower out of Supply
so the normal mode of operation
um we did do Investments to make that
asset the pumping station element more
reliable and particularly something
called a pressure reducing valve because
it um those pumps could blow up the
network so we installed that to make it
more resilient we actually replaced the
generator with a new generator but it
failed we actually replaced the what we
call the connectors but that particular
one failed which we try and we're trying
to understand as to why so we did put
safe safer modes what we believe would
have been safer modes of operation to to
enable us to do that work whilst trying
to do the right thing of extending that
asset which makes the gives it another
10 year 10 years asset life to make it
make it more resilient
um there's lots of challenges in
southern water across particularly I was
obviously I I'm from the water side I
can't actually speak entirely for the
Wayside from a water side there are
there are investments and there's a lot
of activity we need to do to make the
whole asset-based more more reliable
um so and it's not a quick fix
unfortunately so if you look at say
Borough water supply Works which feeds
our Kent area our biggest water supply
Works in this area and is looking at 100
million pounds of investment to put a
lot of those backups in but it's complex
and it's not something we can do in
weeks or months it's years of activity
in fact that that particular project
finishes in 2031 so it's going to take
time so
um so in answer your question we are
working on it but it's not completed yet
it's going to take a take time to do
those activities
um in terms of the question around the
long term and where we've come from and
where we've got to get go to
um if you look back over the last 30
years in in the industry and Southern
wolf particularly there have been
improvements so if you look at low
pressure you're 10 times less likely to
have a low pressure instant Supply
interruptions four times less likely to
have a supply Interruption leakage is 50
lower than in 2000
um if you look at the waist the waste
side and the number of bathing Waters
that are good or excellent was 27 in
1990 is now 83 so there have been
improvements
um the issue is and these things take a
long time
and we need to go faster and that's what
we're putting in our biggest
monetary value into our business plan in
between 2025 and 2030 to try and improve
it faster but it's not quickly quick
because this these assets across
Southern water and all the water
utilities needs a lot of investment to
take them into the from the Victorian
era really to the to the modern era so
it's just going to take time I'm afraid
there have been improvements but it's
just as I say it needs to go faster and
harder with the investment plans we put
in put in place
thank you very much councilor Curry
please
[Music]
I'm just going to whiz around the
committee first and then please wave at
me to make sure I don't forget Council
Curry please Thank You Cher thank you Mr
McMahon for your presentation
um after what seems a very long period
without any real Improvement
it does seem that southern water appear
to be trying to fix things at last my
original question was partly covered by
the presentation so on the same subject
will these repairs actually fix the
problems and can you guarantee
businesses and thanet residents that
these issues are and will be resolved
thank you
um
so actually in terms of the investment
as you as you relayed there's been
activity and we will continue to do that
activity for the the tower and booster
station in question
um
the risk is definitely reduced I can say
that with confidence I can't guarantee
it will never happen again
um but take pipe burst as an as an
example that there's about 50 different
reasons why a pipe can burst it's very
difficult to understand where and when
it will burst there isn't um there are
not any tools in the industry that can
tell you the sort of the pipe thickness
and you can put in a pipe and really
understand where a pipe might burst for
proactive investment you therefore need
to replace lots of lots of pipe which is
very very expensive
um so it's I can't I can't guarantee all
I can say is the instance that we've had
had are now markedly reduced by the
tower being in Supply the work we've
done and the work that it will continue
to do over the next six months are
improving the the controls to the to the
pumps
thank you very much councilor Huxley
please
thank you chair thanks Tim for your
presentation
given that the water industry in the UK
was privatized way back in 1989 why have
there been multiple Wastewater and
sewage legs at fullness pumping stations
than it since 2017.
under Southern Waters ownership is this
unacceptable situation due to a lack of
infrastructure investment by the company
over 30 plus years and the company's
culture of prioritizing payments in its
share to its shareholders up to 2017
rather than naturally looking after its
customers needs in the long term thank
you
Construction
[Applause]
and also I mentioned a few figures a a
minute ago
um reference the improvements since
since privatization I think if you look
look back in time
um to the to the 80s and when
privatization happened
um the the performance on the of the
water sector both on the war side and
the Wayside
um was not good
um was not good there was had been
historic really lack of lack of
investment and you can you can see that
in the
um sort of key figures so if you take
the waste side as an example
um only 30 percent of Wastewater was
treated properly in the 1980s and
bathing Waters they were good excellent
was at 27 now at 83 percent
um now 95 of Wastewater is treated
properly so there has been lots of
improvements
um but as I said before we need to go
faster and harder as an industry
um our stance is very very clear at any
discharge of waste be it legal or not is
not acceptable not acceptable and we are
working very hard to improve it so as I
said you know if you look at the
investment over the last year around the
board stairs and Margate pumping station
and waste five million pounds making
them 24 7 covered is is a is a really
important piece of work that we've put
in put in place are combined to out for
task force we believe is industry
leading we're doing Lots in this space
you've seen obviously you would have
seen beach boy in the openness we're
trying to create an industry of this is
what was happening with our assets being
very open and honest and transparent
compared to potentially others in the
industry something we really are trying
to push
um and our Pathfinder work with confined
sir outfalls to try to stop the water
entering the sewer is something we're
working very hard on and if you look
here in this particular area in question
or install installing a a sud
sustainable drainage scheme to to reduce
water into your sewer we're working with
10 schools to reduce runoff from roofs
that enter the sewer looking at two
parks to look at how we can can hold
water back before it enters the sewer so
we're doing lots of Trials and studies
to look at the most economic way of
resolving these problems in the in the
future
so I hope that answers the question
around it looking back and what we're
trying to do to go going forward
thank you very much come to the eights
please
thank you chair and uh thank you Tim for
coming today
um firstly thank you for apologizing
um I think it is needed and like you
said it is not acceptable and it should
have been better I think we all agree
agree to those uh statements you made
here tonight so I've got two questions
first one's just about accountability
um have any have any staff actually been
reprimanded over what has happened at
broadstairs and what's happened to our
residents
um you show for outages on your
presentation tonight but according to
resident information they've been
tracking this they've been close to 20
outages since 2019.
so that's this isn't a situation that's
just been happening in 2022 late 2022-23
and they're recording two in 2019 three
in 2020 one in 2021 around seven in 2022
and this year alone we had about five
um so and if if there have no if there
haven't been any reprimands for staff
then surely that just shows
um that this is business as usual for
southern water that's my first question
um second question
with Southern War to be willing to
return to this chamber in a year's time
um to actually
show that you are going to come back
here and that we will go through the
numbers again with you to ensure that we
are being held to account
um and whilst you answer those two
questions I'd just like to return a bit
of metal fencing that came off your
facilities
over just over the last week on landed
on our beaches so I'll do that as you
answer the question thanks
so in terms of the um
reprimanded
um
I think it's important that we
understand you know the
key key challenges facing sort of the
team and the business with some of the
assets and the state of the asset so
um and our overall performance so I
guess
has there been anyone who's who's been
impacted yes so my my the person prior
to me in this role
um if I'm going to start beating the
role for five months my role is to
um improve processes people procedures
and all these type of things to improve
our performance I've got a lot of
experience in turning around water
businesses and improving water
businesses so it might you could argue
my predecessor was not through these
events but through not for various
reasons around around performance of
this is part part of so you asked a
question yes it's not the team on the
ground it's my role is to make sure the
team the ground have better tools to to
better respond and stop these things
from from happening
um in terms of one year time absolutely
more than happy to come um it'd be good
to time it in with our final
determination and for our price review
so I can be specific on where we will
actually do future main replacement as
an example
um which might be more like 15 months
time but we can we can work work around
that
um thank you for the fence line we just
I did see that on Twitter earlier on the
fence we need to understand what
happened there again apologies for that
and thank you to the customers who are
alerted to that after that the fence has
been fixed but I need to understand we
need to understand why that occurred
because that shouldn't have occurred for
such a solid piece of apparatus so we
need to understand that and we'll
investigate that and feed that back once
we once we know more
thank you thank you go to the Smith
please
thank you chair and thank you um uh Mr
McMahon
um I I commend your
um your bravery in in being here and and
um your um Grace Under Pressure
I have two questions one is
um
it's harking back
to the uh the question about your
um ability to comment on planning
applications for large housing
developments
I've seen what is published
um with the planning applications and it
I I could be paraphrasing but I think it
says it's all right we promise tick
and and I what I actually want to ask
you is whether there is no way of making
any kind of comment about the
consequences of adding twenty one
thousand four hundred new homes
in Spanish between now and 2040 on your
ability to supply reliable drinking
water and to not despoil our Coastal
Waters and the other question was
given that southern Water Supplies an
essential of the life-saving resource
on a monopoly basis what possible
recourse
do residents businesses or local
government have
if you fail in your
corporate Duty
that's it
[Applause]
microphone please Tim sorry thank you
chairman um I think in terms of the 21
400 properties we'll definitely take it
away just to sort of confirm that we are
supporting it or not I think in terms of
the the comment
um we can comment on it we can't reject
or approve it but we can as you say
say what we what we need and what the
conditions are but we need to get it up
as early as we can in the process so I
need to go away and check and confirm
with the team as to are we being as firm
as we should be around
um the constraints that we have on our
on our system on a network
um in terms of the the impact or the
recourse that we we feel if we fail or
not do teach your question there's
there's lots of sort of factors that
that get played into from our regulator
but
um but the pr the principal activity if
we fail on particular performance
measures so that for water would be
leakage or the example we saw here
around Supply interruptions or
interruptions of customer Supply on
waste would be pollutions or sewage
treatment work compliance are impacted
through Us by something called
outcome delivery incentives so they are
the reward and penalties the economic
regulator enforces upon us so if we do a
good job you get a small reward if you
do badly you get a penalty and we are
very much in that penalty threshold the
regulator has set
um a very very stretching Target upon
the industry
um for this for this price review for
2020 to 2025 and from day one everyone
had to achieve that always an upper
quartile performance company across the
across the board which for southern
water for context is in some areas is a
10-fold Improvement in performance and
if we don't do that we incur penalties
so for this incident as an example
um you saw the sort of the number of
circus 600 000 pound on the GSS costs it
actually cost us probably to tune on
five million pounds in terms of the
penalties we incurred obviously the
emergency costs we had to put in place
water tankers or bottled water and the
the GSS costs so we see impacts from
that and if we are seen not to to
perform in the way that our license
condition
um guarantee it requires the regulator
has
a responsibility to come in and for
something called a section 19
undertaking which is where we have to
commit to various plans to improve proof
performance happens relatively ready in
the industry but Southern water are a
year away from completing our one around
waste water which is obviously well well
known we've actually completed 98 of our
actions the last one is around the final
trains of investment over the next the
next year so there is a piece where The
Regulators if they see that we are not
fulfilling our duties they can come and
enforce that through something called a
section 19 undertaking
thank you very much Council rozeki
please
thank you chair thank you Mr McMahon
uh first we're coming tonight and and
putting up with our questions and
hopefully we'll see you next year for
another round my question comes in
regarding the fullness and the north
Fallen pumps I believe they were
designed initially to to operate for
about six hours at a time
um I'm working with the tide to take
away any
um effluent Etc
from my understanding uh from the planet
fishermen these pumps have been
operating up to 24 hours a day well
outside their design limits and uh due
to this now the fish
in that area out to the three mile limit
are now almost uh non-existent
they put it down to what's been
happening with these pumps and what's
been uh discharged
they would like further engagement with
yourselves they have spoken to you I
believe but they would like further
engagement and I would hope that this
time next year when we sit here I can
come back and say thanks very much for
your engagement with the fishermen thank
you
um I can't comment on that exact pumping
Arrangement Etc but we'll take that away
and come come back to inviting as to
what we our view our views of that and
what we can do if there is a particular
problem on there
thank you councilor Austin
thank you chair and thank you Tim
um I wanted to go into a little bit more
detail on what you've just said about
what what we can do thinking about how
Southern water engages with our planning
department and our planning committee
and what exactly you've said what you
are required by law to do and you've
said about you that sort of level of
Engagement I'm interested in knowing
is does that happen routinely every time
there's a major development does it
happen are you invited to comment every
time that when they build 10 houses at
the top of my street like they've just
done and covered the whole thing in in
uh block Paving and there's no drainage
and it used to be
a field
um Etc what what level of Engagement do
you have and how far are you able to
comment and say well actually if this
developer put in Soca way is it a lot
better for us or those kinds of things
just just those nitty-gritty
practicalities
um
but obviously the bigger development
sort of the the larger developments is
it's
easier to
illustrate the impacts that has because
of the the volume of water that might
come in to be needed or that might enter
our our system and usually that has a
lot more engagement at the earlier start
of the process so we can influence
through the local plan
yeah obviously very it varies from sort
of council to council but in the main
for this area it's it's good it's really
good so
um it's it we are we are invited
um in term in terms of the more sort of
a smaller development it is you it can
be harder to sort of um influence
influence that as part of the housing
plan
um
but we again we do get get invited to do
that but it's harder to sort of
illustrate the impacts for it
um and then as I say if if that
development gets approved we cannot
reject it we have to we have to support
that development through the investment
we need to put in place but you couldn't
advise quite strongly that there's
really going to be a problem indeed yeah
thank you very much counselor Boyd
please
thank you chair
um thank you Tim and John for coming um
welcome to lovely Margate I hope you've
enjoyed your visit somewhat
um I've got two questions
um the first one is uh are the
improvements planned and that you keep
referencing based on current figures of
households or future increases of
households
um do they also take into account the
resilience needed due to adverse weather
weather caused by climate change that
we've seen in recent years so how far
forward have you been planning in terms
of your improvements because they might
be all right for now but if they're not
sustainable or resilient for later so
that's the first question do you want to
answer that first or do you want me to
go straight in with the second cool
um the second one is do you look at
funny as a whole
for land in which rain water can easily
be absorbed in liaison with planning so
looking at the local plan and also in
relation to that are there geographical
comparisons in other areas in terms of
the ratio of density of built up areas
to on developed land so when you're
looking at thanet as a district can you
compare it to other districts to see
what is the ratio of how much built up
Land There is to how much porous land
that actually is required because as you
said earlier one of the best ways to
avoid the overwhelming amount of sewage
is to stop the rain water going in and
so that's my second question thank you
so in terms of
um water and waste work Works slightly
differently in terms of
planning approaches
um obviously I can answer water slightly
more strongly than waste so so water we
work to an 80-year projection around
growth and climate change
and that is why we are looking at Water
recycling or desalination plants looking
at pipe work all the way from the
northern England all the way through the
seven the Thames to Hampshire and then
pumping it Eastward so that's something
the Water Resource Management plan that
gets issued in the summer of this year
so that is very much part of our our
plans and future future projections for
population growth and climate change and
they ask that's quite severe in in the
future for the southeast which is you
know scarce of water drier than Istanbul
so there's something could we invest a
lot of time in his industry and there's
coming to a point now where there's some
quite
challenging decisions to be made with
significant investment requirements
um that may or may but may or may not be
delivered through southern water there
might be other routes that that happens
so so in terms of our
um particularly for the bigger growth
items the 20 odd thousand properties
that goes into our growth plan that then
feeds our Water Resource Management plan
that then feeds our decision making
around what what's what's needed
particularly around the bigger
infrastructure
um
the um
I guess the question around
um how we do more becomes a waste or
energy waste so we've just um we've just
created something called the drainage
Waste Management plans on waste which is
trying to conjure up the same approach
as the water sides to the wrmp so that's
the first time we're submitting these
plans which is all about looking at
growth Horizons and trying to invest in
the network
ahead of head of the need ahead of
growth as opposed to a developer coming
in doing it almost retrospectively so
you do it the bigger investment ahead of
ahead of need and we are looking to put
in a big growth investment plan as part
of our combined throughout full program
to look at how we reduce water entering
sewers but also expand our sewage
treatment works to deal with increased
flow that might happen through flash
flooding or through future future growth
so that's the sort of similar similar
approach that we're feeding into our
into our regulator with all these things
um you know this is why the final
determination or Price review of our
regulator is so important because we
will submit a plan which we believe is
the right thing for performance and risk
and customers bills
um but it's a it's a big challenge for
us going forward because the demands our
customers are rightly setting for the
things we've been talking about
cost cost money
um and we've got a task with the water
companies and Regulators to try and get
that right balance so it's affordable
for customers but doing the right thing
for the long end the short short term so
that will have to go through this
process over the next year which may or
may not lead to the right outcome for
what we think is right for customers it
might mean other work we need to do with
our Regulators
um in terms of your question around
um than it as a whole how do we work out
the modeling and the sort of the size of
the pipes and what's what the inundation
or infiltration of water could be the
approach we use for both water and waste
is we all look to model the system to
understand how much flow is in the
sewers or how much
flow is going through our water pipes
um sometimes you need to build hydraulic
models to do that sometimes that needs
investigations and Sewer level monitors
put into the network to understand
what's what's happening
and from that we were able to articulate
whether we can deal with future growth
in that area by running different
scenarios through it I'm not sure I
fully answered your question around the
sort of permeable impermeable because I
I I'd have to take that away but it the
if you have a um it kind of where we do
hydraulic modernity and waste we which
that particular question impacts if
you're getting lots of infiltration into
the network
um that's captured in your hydraulic
model so you can then run scenarios of
future growth on there so if you get
more water entering the soil sewage
enter in the sewer you can run that from
today's state of play so the fact that
fanet might be more more impermeable
surface than other areas kind of doesn't
really matter for the way we do the
hydraulic modelings it takes the state
of play today and then you build on top
of that
clearly what we need to do is work with
developers and drive better legislation
to ensure that there isn't runoff into
sewers we have permeable driveways we
have water butts to collect so it to
collect rainwater we stop the right that
Highway drainage can connect into sewers
shouldn't be allowed so there's things
like that we should do to stop that from
happening in totality
um but it I probably need to write you
just to sort of confirm the process a
little bit more because it's quite quite
complicated but fundamentally we have a
view of what's entering the sewer today
um and then we build and projections off
it based for future growth and that is
the way that we can sort of articulate
and confirm whether we can account for
that that future growth in the future so
it doesn't really
matter in terms of the current permeable
in permeable surfaces that we've got to
actually model how it works how it works
today
thank you very much
um
members I'm going to go to uh councilor
tanning and then I'm going to wrap up by
asking councilor Keane if she would come
back with with her supplementary just by
way of your information we have been on
this subject now it's a huge subject I
know but we have been on it for an hour
and a quarter I am conscious that these
two gentlemen may have Journeys to make
and so uh I think I would really like to
wrap it up after counter Towing and then
cancel the king please
thank you Chef thank you for your
presentation
we went through the fact that you've got
a lot of upset people over here as I'm
sure you appreciate of all the errors
that have occurred
uh in recent months my interest is the
the vast amount of new developments that
are taking place now and in the future
now I do I do know for my dealings with
Southern water that you're involved in
in surface water controls a deal and
invisible
well obviously as we those are new
developments in those areas
what what are you proposing or where are
you proposing to bring that type of
situation to us over here in Margate to
control that because
um I know that surface water is a big
problem it floods the system and that
creates discharges you know and that's a
fact of life and that's something that
you're desperate to control
and as we're having discharges here
surely these new water baths that I have
talked with Southern water about where
there are two Chambers
and one chamber fills up and the bottom
chamber disperses the water over a
gradual basis which I think is a great
idea uh so you know I think that's
something that we over here would like
to know when that sort of system is
going to be put in place for all our
developers in in Margate
uh and friendly I'd just like to say I
thank Southern water for their support
to have given a local volunteer group in
my ward for Beach please through the
winter and litter picking and I'm
grateful for that and I hope that you
guys will continue to support us and
keeping the beaches clean throughout
there thank you very much
and they thank you for your question
um in terms of
um stopping surface water entering the
sewer and what we doing in that space
um the first place we welcome the
government's
um lightly change to policy where all
developers need to have a sustainable
Learners training scheme in place for
them to have the right to connect
um that is hopefully going to be
legislation in 2024 if not earlier and
that will therefore drive a step change
into those types of solutions that will
answer that that point that aside
um through the works and trials we're
doing across the whole for southern
water patch in different geographies and
sort of urban rural areas the reason why
we're doing those trials is to
understand what is the most economic way
to address
water Ingress into our sewers and from
that that will form our plan plans for
the next five years and the um
because that would say can be a large
price tag required to sort of reduce
um discharges through our for our
outfalls
um but the way we're trying to do it is
to make sure we're looking at the most
cost and most economical way of doing
that to protect customers and stopping
these big Bill shocks that could come if
you went for a solution of big civil
infrastructures a big tanks basically
which will cost a fortune looking at
different ways to stop it even entering
the sewer through sustainable worm and
drainage some examples alluded to
earlier on with some of the trials we're
doing here around schools as an example
are Paramount Paramount to that
in terms of cleaning cleaning the
beaches yes we'll continue to protect
that and support that
um clearly we don't want to happen at
all
um that's that's the that's the key aim
for us but as I say that's going to take
time but in terms of our commitment to
support support our beaches yes we'll
continue continue with that
thank you very much
councilor Keenan please if you'd like to
come back thank you you've obviously
given us a lot of information tonight so
we'll have to sort of go and work our
way through that one thing I just wanted
to really pin you down on though has
there been a root and Branch review of
the emergency measures and I know you
can't sort of promise that there'll
never be any incidents again but have
you done everything is everything in
place to prevent these in future thank
you
can I just um care for the question for
me so when we say emergency message you
mean if we do have a failure how we
respond or to stopping them from
happening completely or how we respond
um it's to stop it happening completely
that you know the generators you've got
are going to perform whatever other
backup measures you've got in place are
working as they should
um so in terms of rumsfield
um rumfield's Tower
um I would say and the tower in is good
news because it gives us that six hour
storage
um over the next six months we will
improve that booster station to enable
us to deal with these power fluctuations
we've seen
um there is some other work to be doing
around
um a particular valve what one can use
to get water in if we do lose both
supplies as well that we're trying to
trying to try and to enhance
um so I'm confident with those things
the risk will reduce I can't say We'll
guarantee it because pipes as I said
before pipe any pipe can burst it's very
difficult until we do the significant
major placement program that we want to
do between 20 25 and 2030
um final determination aside
um
I can't I can't guarant guarantee we'll
be able to stop it from happening but I
can definitely assure you that the risk
will reduce from what you've seen
historically
um I think it's reported in terms of
emergency measures we have in place
um some of the Investments we've done in
this place in in southern water over the
last two years to improve our response
are quite marked from where they were so
um we can now Supply water tankers we
have our own Fleet of of six so in
actually in the rums field event
December we had we used 12
um our bottle of water response is much
stronger than what we've had
historically and we can do up to four
times the amount of vulnerable we can
supply up to four times the amount of
vulnerable customers that we could have
done nine months ago through new
contracts we haven't have in place we've
changed our whole event procedures
to better manage these events and
respond better through better governance
and controls and working with our local
resilience forums to understand where
um
improving those relationships so we can
respond better in events through joint
joint joint ventures and Joint
conversations then maybe what have
happened in the in the past so if they
so we try to do two two parts obviously
stop it from happening is key but if it
does happen we have we have made massive
massive changes to our operation to
better respond if if need be
um and you know it we will con that will
continuously improve we review every big
event to understand how we can enhance
our service going going forward
um and it still needs to it obviously it
needs to get better and it will get
better every time we learn from these
these incidents
thank you very much indeed
um it's been a very interesting
uh hour and 20 minutes thank you very
much for your input I know it's a very
difficult subject and not everybody will
be 100 happy with things as they stand
at the moment but hopefully
um uh we have something that we a better
understanding at the very least of of
some of the difficulties you face I
should have said at the beginning Tim
McMahon you are the director of water
operations I say so now for the benefit
of those uh listening on on the
recording and John mealy you are the
stakeholder engagement manager uh thank
you very much both for coming by your
presence here which was as I say again
an invitation
um Southern water have shown a
willingness not only to speak with
Council but also to speak with residents
members of the public as shown by your
two meetings today and we look forward
to this kind of communication
um
continuing I hesitate to use the word
consultation but Consulting with the
public
continuing on into the future for
everyone's benefit thank you very much
for all that you have shared with us us
this evening
to the panel now if I may we have two
options one is as a result of the
presentations and the question and
answer session to as a panel not take
any further action at this time or as a
panel to make a recommendation or two
that cabinet may wish to consider
councilor Curry
thank you chair yeah I would like to um
invite Southern water back in a year's
time and uh to see how the repairs have
gone see how the improvements have gone
and to talk to councilors and residents
once more thank you
so now my writing thinking we would do
that through
the leader of the CEO or appointed
officer
well it's it's effectively a
recommendation or to the new panel to
the new panel not to Covenant no no no
okay
forgive my error it's a recommendation
to the next panel not to the cabinet
any further recommendations I think I
think that's that was covered quite well
and thank you for formalizing that we
will do that make a recommendation
um that you come back and share with us
some more progress and hopes for the
future in the meanwhile though thank you
very much I'm now going to take a recess
and close the meeting for a few moments
to give you time to gather up and to
leave and to the members of the public
who may wish to leave the meeting at
this point uh do please do so and thank
you very much for attending and joining
with us on this very important issue
okay I'd like now to reconvene the
meeting thank you to those who've Taken
part thus far
um
we're now moving to a gender item number
five the TDC and Parish Town council's
collaboration working party report
um before I ask councilor Curry to come
and present his report to us I'd like to
invite uh councilor Hudson from
birchington Parish Council he's the
chairman of that Council to say a few
words you'd like to speak on this item
councilor Hudson please
good evening chairman ladies and
gentlemen
thank you for allowing me to speak
I represent birchington Burcham Parish
the parish and the town councils are in
fact the first tier of local government
but then you understand that because you
are working in local government and we
have similar objectives
the problem without here is quite often
we don't have a good
contacts with the tier above us
I in this case standard District Council
we've had a period of the last four
years or so when I appreciate things
have been difficult for thanet Council
but
contacts and communication between the
parishes and offices of the district
haven't always been good
all right welcome the report from the
working party that's before you this
evening and I implore you to accept
their recommendations we have had had uh
consultations with them during the
course of their work
um and the recommendations they're
putting forward to are absolutely solid
I can tell you because I do work with
the Kent Association of local councils
many of the districts and boroughs
throughout Kent do actually have these
things in place where they have regular
contact with the parishes with the
parish councils the officers of the
Paris and things work a lot better and I
would hope that if you accept the
recommendations of the working group
that things will be better here in
thanet
and there's two-way Communications we
can offer sometimes things for Senate to
do for the residents they're all your
residents as well and by sharing some of
the workload it is to Advantage chairman
you've had a long meeting I won't keep
you any longer
um but um
I'll be polite and please please support
the recommendations in full thank you
thank you very very much for coming to
speak to us I'm now going to
change my glasses
I'm now going to first of all invite the
councilor Curry to come and sit this
side uh to talk to us
I'm going to break with tradition here
but really I think I think it's going to
be easier
it's going to be easier for Casa Curry
to actually look at you while he's
talking and not have to turn his head
all the time
um uh so uh thank you for that uh
welcome to the top table
feels pretty good
I don't know I might not be here for
much longer
but thank you very much for coming um
and I'd like you to take us through your
report in your own in your own time in
your own way please thank you
well I hope uh members have had time to
look at the report I mean we've made
nine recommendations we didn't want to
recommend uh too many we thought quality
not quantity
so without further Ado firstly I'd like
to thank my fellow working party group
members councilor Austin councilor
Bailey and councilor fellows who along
with my selfish chair made up the TDC
and Parish Town Council collaboration
working party thank you also to parish
and Town Council Representatives
cabinet members and Senior officers who
attended the various sessions where the
working party gathered evidence that was
used to come up with this report
it has been a really interesting
exercise I think we all enjoyed it it
was it was a quite an eye-open
especially for someone who is in Margate
and we're trying to get a Margate Town
Council hearing people that actually on
the front line and uh and there was an
awful lot of agreement as well among um
everybody who attended the meetings
so it has been a really interesting
exercise for us as counselors to get an
insight into what parish and District
councilors as well as officers think
about how we can improve effective
working between the districts and
parishes a number of ideas have been
identified in this report many of which
were proposed by all parties if
implemented we feel this would
successfully lead to a more effective
approach for collaborative working for
the benefit of our residents around the
district
I would also like to thank TDC officers
especially Charles and Nick
for their input to support this review
for their invaluable help in putting
this report together also Democratic
Services as well I know the team has
really helped out here with the ever
tightening of budgets year on year we
feel that if the recommendations can be
implemented this will hopefully make a
big difference to how services are
delivered for our local communities
after considering reports we hope
members will adopt the recommendations
to cabinet for their consideration thank
you
thank you councilor Curry members any
comments to make about reports Council
fellows please thank you chair I'd like
to thank our councilor Hudson and Miss
bever news Mike Clark and my chairman
from birchington to come along this
evening but so firstly I'd like to
acknowledge my colleagues who I worked
with putting the review together
especially councilor Curry you Chad and
Nick and Charles who facilitated
everything I think when we uh first met
sitting there with a blank piece of
paper in front of us we didn't know
where where he was going to lead us but
I believe end up with a great document
with some great recommendations and I
hope whoever's in the front bench is
after May can take the opportunity to
take these recommendations forward we
are a cross-party group and I hope
there's a cross-party cooperation in the
implementation of the recommendations I
think the spirit and direction of the
review is excellent I don't think we
have our 10 approach clocks and shares
who gave us their thoughts uh to put
this paper together and thank for that
we're encouraged that the town and
Parish councils are willing to get stuck
in and take on more tasks in their areas
but this has to come with some support
as well but be it Financial or
administratively I think it's time to
give our town of Parish councils more
autonomy that they so long for as well
and I hope that Margaret can get their
term Council soon
I think the review could also lead to
more clarity for residents who also like
to know who does what in our district
and this could also lead to further
recommendations coming forward addiction
only lead to make an arrows better for
our residents and I'd just like to say
because I've been involved with both of
the reviews this year
um one that actually LED on to the other
one and I hope
after the elections and going forward
that we can do more cross-party reviews
I think uh
found it'd be a better place if we work
more cross-party collaboratively thanks
much come see Yates please
uh thanks chair um yeah and amazing
report I just wanted to ask a quick
question on recommendation one
um this Parish Forum just just for
clarity I think I know the answer but
does that include the Margate Charter
trustees then until such times they have
them down Council
um so that Parish form will there be any
involvement with the Clark there in that
thanks
I'm not absolutely sure whether Margaret
childhood trustees are involved
because I haven't been held for a while
okay
yeah so so Margaret Charter trustees
will uh definitely be in great stuff
thanks yeah
members any other comments about the
report as as we have it
uh
recommendation number nine if I can just
mention that one uh share an up-to-date
TDC officer and member structure chart
with contact details that can be shared
with parish and town councils
um
I assume that is designed to stay within
the elected members and the officers of
those councils and it's not something
that would then be just made public we
do need to protect
Council officers to a degree
um so I just had a just a little
question about number nine
um
so um
members we we have this opportunity to
accept this report in full for ourselves
and uh send on then those
recommendations to Cabinet I did note
there is a possibility that it might be
considered by a cabinet on the 16th but
if that's too tight it would be the next
one I'm not sure exactly uh when it will
be I don't it'll likely to be the next
one
um but then
perhaps I could invite you to propose
that we
forward all the recommendations that we
accept them and forward them to cattle
I can chair I propose that we fall
forward all the recommendations to
cabinet
thank you
thank you very much
do members agree
agreed thank you very much
for producing report for us all of you
for your hard work in putting that
together it's a very fair report thank
you members and uh our thanks also to uh
for the benefit of the recording to the
members of the town and Parish councils
who were involved as well their officers
and representatives thank you very much
we moved then on to our next agenda item
uh which is a review of our overview and
scrutiny panel work program do members
have any recommendations they'd like to
make about our program as it stands
okay thank you for that and the final
item on the agenda is the forward plan
and exempt cabinet report list are there
any comments that members wish to make
about that
nope then it only remains for me to
thank everybody for coming and taking
part in the meeting this evening a very
informative meeting
um and I thank you for taking part and
contributing in the way you have done
that concludes the businesses